and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists and today is episode 169
today we're gonna talk about
millionaires right
oh and well sort of right we're gonna
talk about money we're talk about budget
day we're gonna talk about savings we're
gonna talk about student loans we're
gonna talk about how to build wealth
ultimately and yes we're gonna talk
about millionaires - yeah but it might
not be what you think of when we think
of the term millionaire and we have a
friend Chris Hogan here today he's the
author of a new book called everyday
millionaires all Jordan what camera
should I hold this up to right here
alright it's everyday millionaires and
Chris Hogan is here Chris thank you for
being with me absolutely guys it's
always good to be with you this isn't
the first time we've done a podcast
together last time was a live event in
Louisville it was which was a blast yeah
I mean it was a bunch of people and we
had a great conversation so I've got
high expectations from you all all right
well I'm really excited because we we
don't do interviews what we do is we as
you know from our last event we really
just help people answer the questions
that they have and today we're talking a
lot about money before we dive into this
I don't you can't are you still wearing
the back brace Ryan yeah put my shirt
over it Ryan's back on okay no he's
gonna be able to stay for the entire
episode he broke the five vertebrae like
ten days ago yeah and so stay as long as
you can but please leave if you're in
terrible - all right I mean you I'm
doing okay I'm surprisingly feeling well
for breaking my back in five places well
we'll talk more about that during right
here right now I do want to get into
those questions but before we get
started just a quick reminder the
minimalist podcast is taking February
off so this is our last episode before
that but we're still gonna record for
private podcast episodes for our patreon
supporters so shout out to our patrons
will still be over there for you and
then we're coming back to our main
podcast feed in March with a new format
more details on that later in the show
now Chris you're here to help us answer
some questions but first could you talk
about why you wrote this book and
really how you wrote the book yeah well
I mean the heart behind it was I wanted
to get to the truth I wanted to know is
it possible to build wealth in America
today I've done some media hits and
there were people with the breh tell me
the American Dream is dead it's not
available you know you have to go to the
right school or be born in the right
place and I know being a part of Ramsey
solutions for 13 years said if you take
the right steps in the right direction
financially you'll get to some
destinations building wealth is possible
right now let's get this out here guys I
talked about building wealth so you can
do the greatest thing you could ever do
with money and that's give right being
able to support and give to others so
this became a personal mission for me I
did my first book retire inspired in
2016 and that was the wake-up call for
America to start to think about their
future the government's are going to
take care of you so you got to be
prepared right but this one you all
remembered mr. Stanley's book
millionaire in the next door okay so you
know this was a thing that it started to
give us a peek into what millionaires
look like and so I wanted to go deeper
go bigger now we hear the term
millionaire we think of this guy on a
yacht or we think of the gold Rolexes on
both wrists we think of the pocket
square we think of what we think of this
thing that's unattainable and also we
also we often think of a thing that I
don't even really want out of life which
is the super phallus excess the
overabundance but when you looked at
millionaires you didn't see you you
didn't see that you saw the almost the
opposite of that that's exactly right
these weren't trust fund babies these
weren't people that hit the lottery
these weren't people that were that were
super affluent flaunting it at all these
were regular everyday people what kind
of people so I mean okay so we did the
largest study that's ever been done we
talked over 10,000 of them all across
the country yes so Tom mr. Stanley
talked to 750 we talked to 10,000 so I
wanted to go big I didn't want a peak I
wanted to deep dive into what do they
look like and the reality is they're not
trust fund babies these are regular
everyday hard-working people the top
three professions of the 10,000 we
talked to number one was engineers which
doesn't surprise you they planned stuff
right and number two that's right
number two was accountants doesn't
surprise me they count stuff number
three blew me away and that was teachers
yeah school teachers so my former spouse
Cary
who I think is amazing she's an
eighth-grade English teacher and you
know what she makes an OK living but I
don't think of that as a millionaire in
fact when we were married we were
spending well beyond our means we had
massive amounts of debt and I thought
the reason was because we didn't make
enough money and if I could just make
more well then of course when I started
making more what I do I went further in
today that's exactly well that's what a
lot of people believe I thought that too
I thought you know what when I start
making this amount I'll get serious
that's not true what happens is your
life stones are growing right and you
don't start giving more Oh
in fact it's funny when I walked away
from the corporate world I was making
$200,000 in the corporate world and I
walked away made $23,000 that next year
I gave more that year than I did when I
was making six figures well and I think
when it number one that takes courage
all right I mean to be able to walk away
from that and to be able to pursue
something you're called to do which i
think is really important but these were
regular everyday people people that you
work beside or live beside and they
don't flaunt it there are people that
were focused no you would have no idea
no idea and that's what I love is that
they were in control and they were
focused 70% of these millionaires give
each and every month you know they live
on less than they make their very
intentional and so these were people
that will happen to life instead of
allowing life to happen to them now why
do you why do you why do we want to be
millionaires because that's the thing
that people often get confused by
because I don't think becoming a
millionaire if I hand your average
person a million dollars that's not is
what was that something was gonna make
them happy however you know I aspire to
be half a million dollar net worth one
day not so that I'm like oh look at me
I'm a millionaire but but I want the
financial security and financial freedom
so that I can not just I not just have
the lifestyle that I want to live which
means having to pay it off mortgage not
living beyond my means or or living in
overabundance but also being able to
contribute in a meaningful way well I
think that that's the given component
that's the thing that drives me you know
that was the thing that I wanted to
achieve I wanted to start some some
scholarship fund support some charities
do some things that were near and dear
to my heart but you set a phrase there
that I think is important and that's
financial independence meaning that you
are
not chained to a job you're able to
pursue what you believe in you're able
to do some things that that matter to
you personally I have a good friend as a
teacher in Cincinnati and he he's he's
financially free but he chooses to
continue to be a teacher because that's
his calling
or at least it's part of his calling
right and he has other passions as well
but not having to be there allows you to
get to be there I like that and that's
so power if it is well we in our study
94% of the millionaires enjoyed their
career okay 97% 37% can plan to continue
working and not retire 64% of them said
they loved their jobs right now when you
love what you do number one you're not
working right you know you're making a
difference and so I just I love the
details this book is broken down it's
the largest research that it's ever been
done on millionaires but also we I give
some content about what to do to put
yourself on the path but the stories are
the thing that blows me away can you
tell me yeah one of the stories well
give us a sniff yeah well Thomas is one
that jumps out at me this guy guys he
grew up rough
his dad was an alcoholic his mom had
some mental health issues so he ended up
being in and out of three or four foster
homes as a young man but despite that he
went on to join the military served his
country came back pursued his degree and
went into education so he was focused on
helping other young people kind of grow
and being a good role model he ended up
with a net worth of 2.7 million dollars
and he's giving on a level that he said
he'd never thought he'd be able to do
and so that's somebody that's making an
impact where they are that's the kind of
professor you want to have in school
somebody that cares about what they're
doing yeah they're just for a paycheck
no however we need to be honest and say
that money is a important part of life
it's that doesn't need to be the primary
driver for doing what you do but we lie
to ourselves when we act like money
isn't important at all it's just finding
out where it lies on the priority scale
and then placing it appropriately within
your life now you did the audio book on
this book yes
I mean I your voice man I could just
makes me want to put my Chris Hogan
voice can you make all of us sound like
yes all right well okay bunch of
listener questions here the first one is
from Emily in Oklahoma City my husband
and I have been paying off debt and
using a lot of paper and a tool in the
meantime we have been almost depriving
ourselves but just being very very
intentional and putting the majority of
our extra money towards debt so I found
that when we do get a little extra money
that we decide to spend I spend a lot of
time thinking about how to spend that
money in researching consumer goods and
almost obsessing over the thing that I
don't want to obsess over a disease so I
was wondering you guys have any tips for
people who very rarely get to spend
their extra money and trying to make you
know intentional buying more about the
purpose and less about the stuff or the
thing itself so the first thing that
stood out to me about Emily's question
is sort of this obsession about stuff
and you know I think there are a couple
types of I think there's a healthy
obsession we can obsess over things that
will improve our life but then there's
like this unhealthy rumination and she
needs to figure out like if she's
actually just spending time researching
buying the things I mean she's spending
her money intentionally I think wow
that's wonderful spend your money
intentionally because there's nothing
wrong with things just like there's
nothing wrong with earning money as a
minimalist everything I own must serve a
purpose in my life and therefore
anything I buy must serve a purpose in
my life or it brings me joy in some way
and I think that's a good barometer for
any of the things that we bring into our
life this is going to truly add value to
my life or am I just consuming for the
sake of consuming right now to make an
informed decision you still must make a
decision
Emily and I think that's that's where
you are right now where you're like okay
I'm just ruminating over this thing and
I'm obsessing over it and and I'm not
actually making a decision
when it comes to buying these things
because I'm more wrapped up in the
process of of buying so a few questions
to ask yourself then Chris I'd love to
hear what you and Ryan have to say first
question I ask myself is kind of live
without it right and I think this is
important for for Emily to ask here when
you're when you're trying to bring these
things into your life can I live without
this thing or then what are the
alternatives and it said another way
like is this the best use of this money
if I'm spending $100 on a widget how
else can I spend $100 maybe it's better
to use that money to pay off some
student debt or some credit card debt
usually it is if you are in debt and
then will my future self be happy about
this purchase quite often we want to
please ourselves in the moment the sort
of ephemeral pleasure of the moment but
will my future self
be happy with this or is it over
indulgent I think about desert quite
often I've had some delicious desert in
the past
very rarely I'm a week later a month
later like wow I'm really glad I had
that second piece of chocolate cake last
night or last week or whenever it was
and so is it over indulgence some
practical tips for you we'll put these
in the show notes a 30-30 rule if it
cost over $30 I'm gonna wait 30 hours to
buy it that just staves off the impulse
that he still needed a day from now then
you can still get it also five questions
to ask before buying that's an essay on
our website last thing I have to say is
regarding debt you you can purchase
ephemeral pleasure but you cannot
purchase financial freedom man tweet
that you can put that in the minimal
Maxim shots good Chris what say you well
I would say you know it's important for
us to be intentional I like that she's
doing that the ruminating on it I think
is where it can start to get dangerous
I like your dollar amount that you set
up I think you you want to spend more
time the larger dollar amount that
you're looking at but I don't want her
ruminating over which paper towels to
buy or or you know that that's where now
you know the intentionality is now
becoming more obsessive-compulsive so
give yourself some freedom you mentioned
we so it means that she's got a spouse
and so it's really important for you
guys to be on the same page
let's talk about it understand what it
is we're gonna buy how is it gonna help
us and then be able to move forward with
it and she said you know they rarely get
extra money in and so I would love for
them to be able to enjoy that permission
to enjoy it's really important
especially when you're being focused and
being intentional yeah absolutely I
think she probably faces what I face a
lot when it comes to buying stuff is
this paradox of choice there are just
like a million options of everything and
the other thing too is you know trying
to find the best deal on something so
like those two things alone can kind of
just make me stilted when I go to buy
something and I think one thing I have
to accept is that a I'm gonna miss out
on a ton of deals like I'm always gonna
miss out on a sale so me ruminating in
trying to find the best price on
something it's typically not worth my
time I'll try to find you know a good
deal but I don't get obsessive about it
to try to find absolute cheapest how can
I save an extra five bucks because
really you know let's say it takes me an
hour to find that you know an extra 10%
off I mean I could probably make more
money in an hour than if I just get went
ahead and accepted you know the original
price that I found the other thing - she
talks about is being intentional and I
think this is a good segue because that
is one of the key ingredients to being a
millionaire yeah that's there actually
five ingredients you want to talk about
kind of what millionaires do what what
you saw consistently among amongst all
these folks yeah well you're right I
mean this book is about being
intentional and being consistent and I
think that's a recipe for being
successful in anything that you do but
looking at this you know obviously
millionaires are very intentional with
their money meaning that they spend in
on purpose they live on less than they
make they attack debt which we all know
debts a thief right because interest
that I pay as a penalty interest at our
earn is a reward I don't want to be
penalized in my wife I want to be
rewarded in my life but they also the
number one tool they use to help them
get to millionaire status 79 percent of
the millionaire said they use employer
sponsored retirement plans so we're
talking 401ks 403 beats and Roth IRAs
here if you're self-employed in Roth IRA
or like a SEP IRA Zepp absol or solo
401k you've got options so the main
thing is that they're investing but also
68% of them said that they use an
investment profession
so not going at it alone right I think
that's really important and in our
society today we tend to have this alone
Ranger mentality this John Wayne kind of
bravado where we want to do things on
our own and not ask for help which is a
recipe for disaster in my opinion yeah
we can't let our ego get in the way of
our progress which means get with people
that are intentional that have knowledge
that you don't they can guide you yeah
Absalon there are so many things you
could tweak there several minimum or
maximum well you know it's it's a what I
was referring to that recipe is is what
I really appreciated about your book you
have these five key takeaways where most
of these millionaires that you
interviewed yes they're intentional but
you know they take personal
responsibility they look in the mirror
and and they take responsibility for
what their situation is they are goal
oriented and it's funny because Josh and
I we are typically not goal oriented and
in fact I can make an argument in a lot
of ways how goals might actually stump
someone but I think with money it is
important to have this this number or
this this this you know account to put
money into that you want to get it to a
certain amount and to keep working
towards that amount and then the last
two things that you talk about on here
is they're hard workers they work their
butts off like you said they're not
trust fund kids they didn't just inherit
a bunch of money they work their butts
off and then being consistent with all
those things consistency is key it is
and those five attributes are things
that people out there can start to do
today absolutely right you can start to
take personal responsibility you can be
intentional with your finances you can
be hard-working you can be goal-oriented
and you can know the building well takes
time and it's not a matter of where you
were born right this is not a DNA thing
right this is a choice thing and I think
when we as Americans make decisions
right we're Americans not Americans
right and so when we make decisions and
we get focused we don't need a
permission slip like you guys remember
permission slips back in grade school
yeah you couldn't go on the field trip
unless mom or dad signed off on it
here's the reality as adults we don't
have a permission slip anymore we get to
sign that thing we get to make decisions
for ourselves about our kids and about
our future and about how we're gonna
impact our communities by giving
absolutely I think one of my favorite
lines from the book is you talk about
how goals they're really they're these
promises that we make to ourselves and
you've real
got a look in the mirror and you know
live up to this property now this I'm
glad you pointed that out right cuz this
time of year people have made
resolutions right right and they've
written down what they're gonna do the
ideas the wishes well I I made a
decision last year I was gonna get
healthier alright so I'm down probably
about thirty five pounds from what you
guys saw me as a slim nobody commented
on below I'm a little testy about it but
I didn't I've been eating a lot of salad
okay
salad is not the meal salad comes with
the meal right and so you know but
that's what we have to do we have to
make decisions about what do I want and
what am I willing to sacrifice to get
there absol right and and I think we
forget that we have that power within
ourselves we get to choose and I want
more people to wake up and make choices
for themselves and not not have this
victim mentality to think that they're
limited from doing something no you can
do it you just have to choose absolutely
well Emily I want to send you a copy of
this book every day millionaires by
chris hogan we're going to send you a
physical copy or if you would prefer the
eBook version we'll be happy to send
that to you as well all right let's move
on oh by the way if you have a comment
for us today if you have a comment or
tip about wealth or money or
millionaires or anything else that we're
talking about today then you can leave
us a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm will air our favorite
comments and tips on the future episode
and stay tuned to the end of this
episode from my favorite part of the
show it's this week's listener comments
and tips Ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it is time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media all right
Chris so here's what we do
we're on Twitter Facebook and Instagram
we're at the minimalists you're at chris
hogan 360 that's right yes indeed and so
we answer questions from social media
during the lightning round
ryan and i each do our best to answer
every question with a short shareable
lesson 140 character response but not
really
we just we ramble on a bit and
eventually we tie it up with sometimes
we don't tie it up at all and you can
find all of our shareable quotes over at
minimal Maxim's com thanks to our friend
Jessica Lynn Williams all right Ryan
who's our first question from all right
first question is from David David
writes the average millionaire has seven
sources
income what are your thoughts on
multiple revenue streams versus focusing
on fewer sources of revenue I don't know
if that is I don't know where that stat
comes from did you come across that at
all when you were no not seven no I
hadn't heard of that and so maybe it's I
don't maybe he's referring to new
millionaires or millennial millionaires
or there's some maybe subset of
millionaires that has seven sources of
income I'll give you a pithy answer and
my short answer here is don't try to
make money try to make something that
adds so much value that people want to
pay for it
now that can be that you're writing a
book that someone really wants or maybe
you're creating something you're
creating art or maybe you're doing
something with your time like you're
educating people and you're doing such a
good job the people would be crazy not
to pay you not to give you the pay raise
not to give you the promotion not to
give you more money because you're doing
you're adding so much value to your
corporation or to your own business that
people want to pay you money for it yeah
absolutely my my pet the answer is this
what you do with your money matters more
than where it comes from and I think you
do such a good job in your book Chris
talking about these everyday people who
most of them aren't making six figures
or a large percentage of them are not
making six figures they're working with
what they have no they really are third
of these millionaires never made six
figures in a single working year so you
know the reality is this you definitely
want to be able to have income streams
money coming in that's why I tell people
to invest money in 401ks or solo for one
case or your SEPs because that's gonna
replace your paycheck later so it's good
to have sources of income coming in but
I think you're right guys the main thing
is to have value make sure you're
serving people and you have your heart
in the right place if you believe in
what you're doing again it doesn't feel
like work it feels like service sort of
a foundation when we first started the
minimalist we were still in the
corporate world so that was one revenue
stream we were earning income or still
still making money there of course I had
my retirement account so that is earning
money on its own that I'm never touching
and so that that is a technically a
revenue stream right even though I don't
treat it like one doesn't go into my
bank account necessarily yeah
right exactly and I sort of pretend that
it's not there that's my future selfs
money that's not my money right and then
Ryan and I we started the minimalist and
we just focused on adding value
eventually we added so much value
providing free materials for folks they
started asking when are you gonna write
a book and so we wrote our first book
and that was really the first way that
we started to make money and then we've
done other things since then we opened a
brick-and-mortar business a coffee shop
down in st. Petersburg Florida with a
couple friends of ours and so that is a
way that we sort of added on top of the
foundation but then we we started a
podcast we started doing tours we
started doing other things that were
these different I guess revenue sources
we diversified in a way but we really
focused on adding value we didn't focus
on one of the ways that we can extract
money out of people I think the key
thing to man is like we saw where the
need was we we listened to our audience
we paid attention to what they needed
and then we reacted it's not like when
we went him and I first got together and
you know bought the minimalists calm for
seven bucks off of Go Daddy we didn't we
didn't say to ourselves alright here are
the here are the million different ways
that we're gonna make money off of this
website it was it was more of a reaction
to what we were doing rather than rather
than just chasing more money I think
that's smart I mean
figuring out where you can serve people
is the best way to be to be to do life
yeah my opinion you wake up excited
about what you're doing and you're
excited to have an impact on people's
lives so I think that's a healthy
approach to life I think also waking up
excited to do what you want to do is one
big measurement of am i living a
meaningful life and ultimately I think
living a meaningful life means you're
your values are aligned with your
actions and one way that you can measure
that is how do I feel when I wake up in
the morning do I actually want to do
this and if not what do I need to change
in order to answer yes to that question
in the future there's our next question
alright our next question is from
Tiffany how much of a role if any did
positive thinking play in Chris Hogan's
success oh wow I can tell you right now
it played every kind of rustic-y a no it
was an amazing impact a huge proponent
of Zig Ziglar Zig used to talk about
automobile university I used to listen
to cassette tapes are
that's back I'm old okay that's this
thing used to slide into the radio you
know but would listen to that and I
think it's really important for us to
make sure that we're feeding ourselves
positive information actually lies in
it's impossible to put negatives in and
expect positives out so we need to be
bringing in positive thoughts but also
delivering positives to other people
what we think about ourselves and how we
view ourselves impacts our actions so I
think it's important for us to guard
that voice in your head if it's not
telling you positive encouraging stuff
it's time to change the track you need
to mute that button and play another
song
absolutely that actually that sums up my
short answer really well I said my short
answer to this is think carefully your
mind controls your actions and your
actions shape your lives and so so or
shape your life I should say you can
edit that Shawn and but I mean I think
positive thinking is a great first step
however we can't mistake it as the only
step either we have to couple it was
action yes you do you have to do some oh
you can sit around and think positive
all day but if you don't get up and do
something but also we hit on it earlier
sacrifice right anytime you're going
after something that matters you're
gonna have to give up some things and I
think we tend to forget that part so as
I set goals or promises for myself what
am I willing to give up and what do I
want to get and I think that's a great
way to balance our focus yes absolutely
my short answer is this incantations are
just as important as brushing our teeth
and I just can't stress that enough what
we tell ourselves well that's what's
going to be true and that's what we're
gonna act on and if you're someone out
there who's got this negative voice in
your head just just you know maybe keep
a gratitude journal dusit wake up in the
morning and just just give yourself one
positive incantation that you can say
throughout the day it really does make a
huge difference
Wow I have a statement guys I tell
people it's hard to be hateful when
you're grateful amen right and when you
look at things so find something to be
grateful for if you woke up praise the
Lord you woke up if you got breath in
your lungs and you walked by yourself
that's a thing to be be grateful for
things and it's easy to find those when
we have awareness yeah absolutely it's
funny speaking of that it's like since I
broke my back I have like appreciated in
my legs so much because I really could
have like really done some serious
damage and man I'll tell you like as
much pain as I'm in I still can keep a
pretty positive attitude being being
appreciative of the things I do have I
have to
you you are amazingly positive standing
there with that back brace off and
walking I'm serious dude you what you're
pushing through and that's what I love
that and that's a lesson in life that we
do have to push through some challenges
they're coming our way it's how we
handle absolutely
well PS gentlemen we have 5 more
questions about student loans about
minimalist expenses about car leases Oh
about occasional splurging while paying
off debt and also about how to establish
an emergency fund plus Chris I want to
talk to you about whether the government
shutdown is ruining our lives
we're gonna talk about all of that if
you want to hear our answers those
questions and more conversation with
Chris Hogan you can listen to this
week's PostScript episode over at the
minimalist private podcast that's right
every week we record an additional
podcast episode and it's available
exclusively to our patreon subscribers
and once you become a patreon subscriber
at the minimalists comm slash support
you'll receive a personal link to our
private podcast feed from patreon so
that it plays in your favorite podcast
app whatever app you're using to listen
to this podcast right now you'll also
get access to the entire back catalog of
more than a hundred private podcast
episodes oh and by the way this is our
final post script episode Ryan Wow and
it's actually I think it's gonna be our
longest PostScript episode yet because
next week we're switching to our new
podcast format and our patreon episodes
will switch from PostScript episodes to
what we're calling maximal episodes
we're doing longer episodes over an hour
long for our patreon subscribers
starting next month
and while the episodes on our main feed
the feed you're listening to right now
will be shorter 30 minute minimal
episodes a lot of people in asking for
that so let's talk about why we're
making this change really quick first
there are a lot of folks who have been
asking for shorter versions of a shorter
version of the minimalists podcast and
some people want a succinct half-hour
dose of minimalism each week they don't
want Ryan and I'm monitoring on for two
hours and that's totally fine as much as
we love hearing our own voices and so
those people who are shorter episodes
they're going to get their wish with our
weekly minimal episodes on the main free
public podcast feed the the podcast feed
that you're listening to right now a
second and
is the big exciting change for me and
Ryan there are some topics that we want
to discuss send me privately I guess in
front of a small compassionate group of
people conversations we'd have with only
trusted friends or family we want to be
able to think out loud in front of a
small group of people who are willing to
give us the leeway to grow and fail and
change our minds in real time and it's
sort of like a way talked about it last
week was a stand-up comic sort of works
out their material in front of a really
small audience first we're gonna use
patreon that way to sort of talk about
some things that are hard to talk about
in public work some stuff out together
and we need to be able to talk about our
failed habits our family lives our
struggles our personal relationships our
emotions and our insecurities without
fear of judgment or public ridicule and
we believe that patreon is the best
place for us to delve into these
sensitive subjects difficult discussions
and of course our silly shenanigans that
Ryan and I are always up to and third
patreon is also the best way for us to
fund our podcast to keep it 100%
advertisement free and because we refuse
the clutter our podcast with ads our
show is a hundred percent listener
funded so thank you to the small
percentage of folks who willingly
support our show we certainly appreciate
it so next month which is February 2019
the minimalist podcast is taking the
month off from our free public podcast
feed the feed you listen to right now
but we're still gonna record for podcast
episodes for our patreon audience these
four episodes will be about four
episodes about products happiness
branding and then we're gonna do this
sort of hybrid episode about
gentrification and also the Marie Kondo
show tidying up and it's really yeah
yeah yeah it's well or have you watch it
beforehand because our community on
patreon is going crazy about this on
both sides oh wow but they're not
fighting with each other they're like
arguing good points like pro and con and
so we've had I think it's was Sean it's
brought over a hundred comments at this
point right he's exhausted just reading
them but we were going through this and
you have people really interacting this
is we are building this community this
private community of people who aren't
being judgemental with each other it's
not like Twitter where people
start like throwing rocks at each other
the hurling pixels at one another as I
heard
very wise say recently and and and we
don't worry about that it's it's sort of
this the safe where we can entertain
these ideas and we can have different
opinions different beliefs and that is
totally ok so if you have questions
about products happiness branding or
tidying up you can leave those over at
patreon.com slash the minimalist we will
be answering those on those private
podcast episodes then beginning March
2019 the minimalist podcast the popular
free public version you're listening to
right now will return with 30 minute
episodes similar to our current format
so we're still going to answer your
questions on voicemail we're still gonna
do ask the lightening round we're still
going to do added value we're still
going to do right here right now we're
still gonna do listener comments and
tips we're just gonna do it within a
30-minute window we're calling these
minimal episodes and then each week
we'll record an additional 60 minute
episode maybe longer might even be two
hours we're calling those the maximal
episodes exclusively for our patreon
subscribers and that's where we'll have
the unrestrained freedom to dive deep
into difficult conversations and it's
worth mentioning that our patreon only
maximal episodes will contain entirely
different material from the minimal
episodes there isn't really any overlap
there so you can feel free to subscribe
to both if you want we're also going to
add a new segment it's called more about
less where we talk about current events
that relate to minimalism and you can
find all the details and all the good
stuff over at the minimalists com slash
support and I want you to please note if
you can't afford to become a patreon
subscribers right now don't worry we
totally understand and we don't expect
you to support the show monetarily it's
totally fine and that's why we'll
continue to produce meaningful podcasts
and essays and videos and other
creations without you having to spend a
dime on any of those so you can still
get all of the free materials all the
free creations that we're putting out
there and for the few of you who choose
to support us monetarily thank you so
much we appreciate it I know podcast
Shawn and Jordan no more appreciate it
that's how we pay them it's how we pay
for the studio space and we're really
grateful alright here is a long snippet
from this week's PostScript episode on
patreon
[Music]
as you've been having this sprint on to
attack debt is just what I want you to
do is once it's all paid off I want you
to shift gears and now let's build you a
cushion this is where you start to build
up an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses I want you to have
that same intensity to get that cushion
in place now once you get that in place
I want you to start investing for your
future so it's a little bit of a
downshift but you're gonna still keep
driving down this path toward financial
freedom let's walk through those baby
steps really quick so you went through
them but let's just give them on a high
level offers old baby step number one is
to get a thousand dollars in place so
you stop using debt alright so number
one number two attacking your debt with
the debt snowball list your debts out
smallest the biggest and attack them
baby step three is to build up that
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses you can do that now that you
got yourself a raise by getting out of
debt then baby step four is investing
fifteen percent of your household income
toward retirement this is where you
start to use the 401 K the 403 B baby
step five is saving for college if you
have young kids baby step six is paying
extra on the house and paying it off
baby step seven is build wealth and give
which giving is the greatest thing you
could ever do with money yeah so they're
at that build wealth stage I mean
they're right where they want to be
right now she owes and one of them is a
minimalist fan the other one's a Dave
Ramsey fan that sounds like the best
team right absolutely best combination
it's like a Oreo
[Music]
Chris I want to say thank you so much
for being here with us today and we're
really grateful I really hope people
check out your new book every day
millionaires I think you're an amazing
person and what you're doing is really
good for the world so thank you for what
you do man thank you for having me
and I'll tell you what I I appreciate
you guys in what you're doing you're
helping people gain perspective you're
helping people to identify what matters
and why does it matter and I think you
know we're all trying to help people
that's what we do and I think that's why
people enjoy talking to us and with us
because they know we're serious about it
we care about people and I just want
people to know the American Dream is
alive and available I want them to grab
it and make an impact on your community
right where you are with your time your
talent as well as your finances you know
it's funny when I talk about the
American Dream I always talk about how
there is still an American Dream it's
just shifted a little bit now debt-free
I think is the new American Dream no I
want people to get there
what I'm doing more of what they're
called to do right without limits
absolutely amen thank you for being with
us thank you my friend thanks man all
right we just finished that patreon
episode with Chris Hogan he had to dip
out he's where he's going somewhere else
already yeah he's out here talking to
people about millionaires actually
podcast Sean and I are headed to his
event with Dave Ramsey tonight as well
so looking forward to that let's move on
to our added value portion of the shows
where we each talk about something that
has added value to our lives recently
I'm gonna talk about two things Ryan one
is a new album sometimes I just go on to
like Apple pot now Apple podcasts iTunes
I guess music that's what it is Apple
music I checked the is the brows and I
was on the singer-songwriter tab and I
was just listening to new music there's
so many new albums out but there was
this one that really struck me there's a
singer songwriter named Dermot Kennedy
and it's a self-titled debut album but
there's this song called power over me
that is like this powerful song it's
exactly how I feel about back so I don't
wanna get too sentimental here but but
uh late there is like there's just pull
you experience this with Mariah where
like she has this pull over you and like
when you're not around her you you miss
her and you want to get back to her and
and there's she has this power over you
in a way
but in a good way not in a not in this
negative way but it it was like this
beautiful expression of love and emotion
and maybe we can play us out with that
at the end of this episode podcast Sean
the other thing we just restring Ella's
guitar this this past weekend and her
and I were doing dueling guitars trying
to teach her how to play a little bit
even though I barely know how to play
but I was doing the chords for her while
she was doing the strumming and teaching
her how to not bang on the like it works
a lot better if you just strum them
softly and and he's he's still working
on getting that down but the thing they
had to value my life was spending $4.50
getting her little tiny cheap kids
guitar restrung cuz she when we first
bought it for a couple years ago within
a day she had broken at least two of my
strings I would have done the same thing
if I was live and I fact I still do the
same thing what's that in value to your
life recently Ryan oh man
well since Christmas here I got to
recommend this book every day
millionaire is just a great approach to
how anyone can really become a
millionaire and and I know we talked
about it during the podcast but he just
does a really good job of speaking to
how it's really what we do with what we
have rather than coming from a certain
socio-economic background or having some
inheritance or you know having some kind
of windfall in our lives you don't need
that to to really save up and to become
a millionaire and and you know I want to
be clear again we touched on this
touched on this in the episode you know
it's there's nothing wrong with being a
millionaire there's nothing wrong with
having money we all need money right the
problem is when we forsake our values we
forsake our beliefs we forsake the
people around us chasing that million
dollars and Chris does an awesome job of
showing how you can still live up to
your values and beliefs and you can
still become a millionaire if that's
truly what you want to do and then the
other way the goal and he makes this
explicit in the book and in his talks
the goal isn't to become a millionaire
the these are people whose goal was to
live a more meaningful life to give more
to be financially free and on the path
to doing that a lot of them a lot of
people rack up a million dollar net
worth and he defines that in the book
too it's not these are people that make
a million dollars a year as he talked
about these are people who
earn most of them at least earn a very
modest income most of them yeah most of
them never earn you know six figures and
they're still able to make responsible
decisions with the money that they have
yeah and then along with Chris's book
I've recommended this before but I got
to recommend it again is the every
dollar app like that budgeting app so
Mariah and I when we were paying off
debt we had a budget and then when the
debt was gone I was like oh we don't
need to budget anymore
well our credit card bills just started
getting because because we do carry one
credit card that we pay off every single
month it started kind of rising and then
it wasn't until you know we moved to LA
and I'm like wait a second like this is
we need to go back to the budget because
this that's really is what empowered us
to pay off our debt and now the budget
it empowers us to save for our future
selves so yeah the every dollar app is
what we use and I got to tell you like
the first month that we started
implementing the budget back into our
lives using everyday dollar or I'm sorry
that every dollar app or credit card
bill went in half and it has not risen
since oh it's crazy dude it's awesome
once you you know there's this old
there's this old adage in the corporate
world you can't manage what you don't
measure and I think a lot of times
that's nonsense people over measure
things we're back in the corporate role
we're responsible for these 29 different
metrics if you start measuring
everything you're actually measuring
nothing you talk about measuring one
thing it's the money that you're
spending right and that is extremely
helpful if you want to manage it you
have to start any measuring well and
here's like the secret I think to
becoming financially stable whether that
means being a millionaire or not which
funny how learning through this whole
experience that you don't need a million
dollars to be financially stable it
sounds like a really nice number and
then that makes you feel like oh if I
reach that million dollars I won't have
to keep track of my money but that's not
what millionaires do millionaires they
they 90 90 something percent of the
millionaires that Chris talked to in
this book kept the budget still kept a
budget but uh yeah I guess I'll just
leave it on that get Chris's book
everyday millionaires check out the
every dollar app it's it's both really
really really empower
anything's let's move on to right here
right now where we talk about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalist
so first off Ryan broke his stupid back
am i stupid back so let's talk about how
you decide I talked about this on the
intro of last week's episode when you
weren't here I was wondering I got all
these lake comments I'm like I text Jess
I'm like where did we mention my broken
back from social media because I had now
I'm getting all these you know get well
wishes which I really appreciate thank
you so much for for all that I seriously
do appreciate it yeah I was uh I was
just snowboarding and not doing anything
I knew I should have talked to you on
white we were on patreon we were talking
about the Shaun White I don't yeah he
ran into me at some ramen place he was
like hey I really like them I didn't
know who he was and and then I loved it
and then Bex was like freaking out oh my
god - Shaun White and then I'm like Ryan
would really be happy if he got to meet
him and so I tell you once about Shaun
White no look I can be Shaun White no
that wasn't it at all man I was I was
just boarding through some trees like I
normally do I mean this is not out of
the norm I probably shouldn't have been
in there because the snow cover was was
not very great it's funny like Mariah
and I went down the first couple Hills
and I wasn't in the trees and I started
looking over there I'm like oh man
there's like just a bunch of fresh
powder in there like no one has been in
the trees well I took a few runs down
had a blast was getting all this fresh
powder but then like on those like maybe
the third or fourth time going through
the trees I just hit this spot that had
about you know three inches of snow and
then underneath of it was ice so I'd
like tried to stop wasn't able to stop
and hurled myself into a tree and then I
realized talking to Mariah's father that
the reason why there weren't a bunch of
tracks in the trees is because the snow
cover was so lame and that it was so icy
so like they people were being smart
smarter than I was obviously so I had to
learn a lesson the hard way but I got to
say like I said the beginning of the
show my biggest bruise I've ever seen on
a human it's believable should I show
the audience no probably not
it's it's in the back brace anyway yeah
that's true it's it's pretty massive but
you are literally the most durable
person
you I've broken a vertebrae and it's
gonna be a hell of a process healing and
in physical therapy is eventually gonna
be such an important part that's the
part I I didn't do for 20 years and I
really paid for it as you know as you
remember as you had to deal with and but
you're at a point right now where you
can't even really you could probably do
some physical therapy but very very
little at this yeah I guess I still like
late I have to sleep on my back like
twisting and like rolling over is
excruciating but if I stand my back like
it's relatively the pain is is
relatively low I mean they uh yeah and
you know mix with like all the meds they
gave me like it in in Tylenol like it
really really takes a little bit of the
edge off but like I said in the
beginning man I am doing pretty well for
breaking five vertebrae man like I feel
I feel pretty good still like we're
standing here right now there's pain
don't get me wrong but uh but man I just
I feel really really lucky that uh it
wasn't worse you know I'm yeah I'm
really grateful that you're still here I
know it's the last minute you decided to
make a turn because you almost went
face-first into it yeah and we'd be
having a much different conversation if
that were to happen because I don't
think you'd be here yeah maybe not dude
what what I mean Sonia Mona that's what
happened to him yeah absolutely my head
first yeah my my thought and I always
wear a helmet ooh and so kids wear your
helmet like that is the most important
thing whether you're riding a bike
whether you're snowboarding I know you
want to be cool and not wear a helmet
well being cool might kill you one day
might get you killed so wear your helmet
um but what else that podcast shot but
uh yeah I was saw myself going
face-first in the tree and I had my arms
out and I was going fast enough for I
was like oh I'm gonna break both of my
arms if I go into this tree so I like at
the last minute tried to put my shoulder
into it and really just put my back into
it instead so it was uh it was a fluke
thing um I gotta tell you when I was
late before I got up so I hit the ground
like obviously fell yeah my left leg was
like numb for like ten 20 seconds for a
second I was like oh no like I have
I have just changed dramatically changed
my life and then after you know after I
started getting feeling back on that leg
and I can move my feet and stuff I was
like oh okay like it was just like this
it was this trauma that happened to my
body and you know maybe I'm okay
I actually got up dude and snowboarded
out of the trees and got to the main
trail where Mariah was and when I got to
the main trail I was like I was in so
much pain I was like oh there's no way I
can make it down the rest of this hill
so think I'm when I was there she was
waiting we always check in on each other
she was waiting for me and I was like I
need a snowmobile she went down the hill
and got a snowmobile I had the whole
like - mock man like hidden in the the
stretcher that they have on the hill
dude and like everyone's looking at guy
it was it was kind of embarrassing but
um you know I got it guy yeah it's okay
man I got to give it up to the team over
lost rail there in and I guess it's
technically like in Idaho as where oh
really yeah
if it's right on the I think half of the
the resort is in Idaho and the other
half is in Montana I broke my back in
Idaho sounds like a country but uh but
yeah Josh Wagner keeps calling me
Brokeback Montana but nah man I gotta
give it up for the team at last rail mat
who like got me basically from you know
where I sat and all the way you know
helped helped me get into the car from
Ryder driving me to the ER room
something funny I don't think I told you
this man we we took Mariah's dad's car
to Lush trail which is a manual it's a
stick shift mariah has not driven a
stick shift since high school but uh but
Matt um not only did he help me into the
car he like helped Mariah you know with
the stick shift to make sure that
someone else was like made sure she was
boarded cool - to drive it yeah dude I
mean it like I said man it's it was the
team was awesome and like all the
support around it I really appreciate it
although I feel like you know there was
a piece of me that I was like I'm never
gonna snowboard again like why do i why
do I put myself in such danger I'm like
way past that now
but definitely wonder hard lesson in
well so I broke a vertebra when I was 13
playing ice the water yeah on ice I was
playing ice basketball right and tackled
me and and then I'm still trying to get
that as an official Olympic sport you
could replace curling I think come on
full contact curling full contact ice
basketball sounds awesome yeah I just I
don't want to play it and realize that I
was playing and and and then when I was
26 I cracked my tailbone I was working
at telecom company we're at I was at
Bridgewater Falls and like fell a cup of
coffee at each and I would do I was
bringing back a cup of coffee for
Ratliff and you know when you squeeze
that like when you fall and like it
looks like up in the air and I cracked
my tailbone and there's nothing I could
do about other than like barely sit down
and the lesson I've learned here is
avoid being anywhere where there's snow
or ice okay totally Sonya yeah you're
invincible then all right well I'm
grateful you're okay thank you for being
here and we're taking obviously February
off and you'll be able to do some
healing then yeah ma'am perfect I'm
gonna break my back really I know we had
this man we had the month of February
planned off you usually not this good of
a planner I know but man I was on it and
ella ella had her surgery last week you
came out and saw her she has this I
talked about it on two podcasts ago on
the collectibles podcast so I won't go
through the whole thing but basically
has the scar on her head they closed up
halfway and she's doing great so thank
you all for your well wishes if you want
to continue to wish her well we're
reading the tweets to her just tweet her
she's at Ella sandwich and she doesn't
have control over that account obviously
but though all the words there are
literally all words that she says so
we're gonna sit down with her and read
all of the the get-well-soon wishes to
her talk about resilient when I when I
was in months
to go and say you know hello to Ella I
was like expecting to be in bed and you
know like oh you're so brave and you
know I hope you get what better soon
when I pulled up I think you guys were
having a snowball fight it was like two
days I had like talked to her I just
talked her out of doing like crazier
things it's like the best thing I could
do was like she wouldn't go sledding I'm
like no you can't go sledding with this
huge you have 50 stitches on top of your
head but I can pull you around on the
sled as long as you don't you know as
long as you stay in the sled basically
and so she actually actually goes back
to school today the day were recording
this and and yeah so she's doing a whole
lot better and and yeah I'm grateful for
that thanks for all your well wishes
folks I have a little bit of a teaser we
have we have two big announcements
coming in March and well let's just say
there's a book in the works and there's
a film in the work so I'm not going to
give you any details right now we're
gonna come back and march on this main
podcast feed and we're gonna talk to you
about some big projects we've been
working on and we're excited to announce
those to you very soon we talked to
Chris about contribution and being able
to contribute beyond ourselves this is
the last time you're ever gonna hear us
talk about this we want a dollar from
you or five dollars from you or twenty
dollars from you or a hundred dollars
from you actually we don't want it it
doesn't go to us at all how close to be
twenty thousand away
no we're 19 thousand away as of this
recording I think we can get there we
got to get there by the end of the month
if we could just talk one person into
donating 19 thousand dollars if you're
out there please do Ryan and I have
donated $25,000 of our own money we're
trying to build a grocery store in West
Dayton 40% of Dayton's population lives
on the west side there's not a single
grocery store over there we're trying to
build a food co-op called Jim City
Market not only will provide fresh
healthy food as opposed to the Cheetos
and liquor that you can buy on the west
side of Dayton now you can't buy real
food over there I mean my diet used to
be Cheetos and liquor I don't know why
they're complained I'm kidding
and nothing but we're also trying to
we're trying to educate and add an
educational component with Jim City Marc
it's not about just providing people
with food but understanding why that
food is is necessary for well-being and
healthy living we really need your help
if you're interested in helping out it's
a three million dollar market we are
nineteen thousand dollars away so close
swing by the end of January if we can
get there we'll have enough money to
begin construction on that breaking
ground the summer and opening about a
year from right now which will be
amazing exciting and will drag will drag
Jordan no more out there well we'll do
we'll do a filming of the grand opening
all that fun stuff as well if you can
donate it doesn't go even through us at
all you just go to the minimalists comm
slash dayton that forwards over the Jim
City Market donation page give whatever
you can give we're really grateful for
everyone who has contributed so far if
you want to comment on this episode you
can do so over at youtube.com slash the
minimalists and speaking of youtube we
just ended season two of living room
conversations I just finished season to
a breaking bed Ryan's Walter White dude
it's funny like being held up the way I
am yeah like this is the most standing
I've done in probably I don't know four
or five days because I was actually kind
of pushing through the first week but
then really screwed myself like the
seventh or eighth day into it is when
the worst pain happened because I was
just pushing through pain but I didn't
realize I was kind of creating more
problems but anyway I've been trying to
lay down as much as possible and you
know when I'm trying to kill some time I
put on Breaking Bad and it is a pretty
addictive show once you get into it yeah
it's a phenomenal show you gotta check
out especially as we're gonna do an
episode about it on patreon next month
the Marie Kondo stuff because it's just
been getting bombarded with messages on
social media and then there's this
billboard outside you can see it from my
living room it says doesn't spark joy
and I have I have some thoughts about it
but I'm gonna wait to discuss everyone's
thoughts because our patreon audience is
the most respectful sort of I don't even
call it debate but it's just different
beliefs and people sharing those beliefs
what are the reality PR people enjoying
the show like is it getting half the
people are like wow this is so helpful
and useful and instructive and amazing I
love it and here are the reasons why
they a big go into debt like people were
writing essays on our patreon page it's
amazing
how the community is interacting and
then you have other people who are like
well tidying up is really just hoarding
and here are the reasons why I think
it's hoarding and those people were
saying that but it's not people arguing
with each other it's just saying here
are my beliefs and here is after
watching the show or reading her book
here's what we get out of it I have my
own opinions I'm interested in what your
opinions are and so the confluence of
our opinions with everyone else's yeah
it's funny like what we do is more of
like the why - or the what - but I think
Marie Kondo she is that you know here's
the 16 ways to declutter your closet
right and that's and that's fun and a
lot of people do need recipes like that
and that's what she provides yeah and
we'll talk about specifically especially
like I noticed in the very first episode
there was this kid who was like counting
his steps as he's walking around they're
cluttered house and he's 1 2 3 4 and I
got identified more with that kid than
anyone else just because I also have OCD
but then it makes me question like huh
does this material clutter calls it does
it does it does it make your OCD flame
up in a way that and and I think we all
know the answer to that but let's talk
about why we'll do that over on patreon
next month
also on YouTube so we finished season 2
of living room conversation you want to
go back and watch those there's 51
episodes of living room conversations a
total and also the tour of my house we
finished filming and that should be out
on Valentine's there I think maybe even
the day before Valentine's Day you can
find that over at youtube.com slash the
minimalists and then we'll go film
Ryan's next how do you feel about there
being 51 episodes it drives me insane
because there's 30 episodes the first
season 21 the second season and
[Applause]
yeah I hate before we wrap up I just
wanna say thanks to Chris Hogan you can
check out his book every day millionaire
is also you can follow him on all the
social medias and
the whole team over there Dave Ramsey
they're just amazing people yeah really
I love them I think I think they're
great they're really helping people and
I'm grateful they're in the world you
can also find Chris on his website chris
hogan 360 dot-com two-hour casual
listeners we will see you in march we
have several great guests lined up for
our minimal episodes Ben Greenfield nice
how Newport whoa his new book digital
minimalism is coming out also TK Coleman
and others patrons we'll see you next
week we're going to talk about products
happiness branding gentrification and
how that relates to Murray condos
tidying up I'm still looking for the
connection there I have a great eye I
have like Urbanists demographers and
then I want to compare what they're
saying about gentrification to what our
audience is saying about tidying up and
I think I have some really good links or
if I don't then it'll be a beautiful
trainwreck so check that out over on
patreon next month patreon.com slash the
minimalists and either way if you are a
casual listener we'll see you in March
or we'll see you if on patreon next
month either way we really appreciate
you listening thank you so much Ryan
what else you got for us as always I
want to encourage people to read more
and get informed now here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hi this is Jill from Winnipeg
Manitoba Canada I heard on your last
podcast about Ryan skiing accent and how
he broke his back several years ago I
also fractured my t8 in T 10 and broke a
piece off of my t9 also in a skiing
accident so I'm calling to offer my
empathy because it really does hurt like
a mother and secondly I'm calling to
offer a tip after three months in a back
brace another three of physio I found
that I had to radically change the way
that I exercised and stayed fit after
the back brace came off I was so excited
but had absolutely no muscle tone which
should have been obvious from wearing a
back brace for three months but I really
hadn't expected it I couldn't even sit
up on my own for more than five minutes
at a time I did physio for the next
three months doing up to eight to ten
hours per day there's a very boring time
in my life since most these movements
were in law
slow stretches and I was used to being
extremely active for years I had
residual back pain from my muscles
either being too tight or feeling too
weak and was really hard to find the
right balance of strength training and
stretching to help my back a friend
introduced me to yoga and it was
absolutely life-changing I highly
recommend Ryan that you find a class
that works for you for me it's been the
perfect combination of strength training
and stretching that I find that I still
need on a weekly basis the good news is
that my back no longer hurts but it's
been a long slow process to get there so
all the best with your recovery and
hopefully you find this helpful
hello this is Jessica from Cincinnati
and I'm calling and regards to Sarah
from San Francisco's question regarding
buying new furniture I have four small
children eight six two and four and we
actually purchased when my young my
oldest was the baby a sir uh sofa from
Restoration Hardware their mother
Lancaster collection and it was the best
investment we could have made the great
quality has held up through all four
children the leather surface has been
amazing for wipeable problems you can
use your imagination on what that means
and also the awesome thing with
Restoration Hardware and other companies
that are a little bit more expensive is
that they do have store model waiting
lists which is what we did we put
ourselves on a waiting list for a store
model that had a tiny scratch in the
back so they couldn't sell her for a
full price and we received a 40%
discount so if you do find a so slowly
you find furniture from a expensive
store or a high-end store and you're
okay with a little bit of damage
especially if you have small children
that you're worried may do more damage
that's a great option to be on the
waiting list for the next available
available floor model and then that way
you get high in great quality for less
hi my name is Beth Ann's from Virginia
I'm a longtime listener and lover of
your podcast and other media I just
recently finished an audio book on Kubla
which is a fantastic program where you
can use your public library card to
borrow up to five items per month from a
huge database of audio books and music
etc not all library systems participate
but everyone should absolutely check to
see if their local library does because
it's a pretty valuable resource but upon
finishing this audiobook I immediately
started listening to the baggage episode
of your podcast and realize that this
book called unfuck your brain by faith
Harper may benefit anyone who feels any
foremost affair from baggage and must be
honest if you're human you have baggage
so it's truly an eye-opening book with
great insight on vanity depression
emotions and how you're feeling in
everyday life and she uses a lot of wit
I'm swearing which are basically two
things that allow me to function in my
daily life so hoopla and st. Harper -
added value items to better your life
today
all right Jo that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm and if y'all
live here today with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time
oh podcast Jean let's play them out with
some Dermot Kennedy power over me unless
you're on YouTube then just click on my
face and you'll be able to see the video
and minimus